[Musique]
il a été retrouvé noyé dans la vologne
une rivière des vosges il avait les
poignets liés et une cordelette autour
du cou le petit grégory quatre ans a été
assassiné et le meurtrier a téléphoné à
la famille après avoir accompli son
geste horrible qu'on sache chanter c'est
dans cette rivière qu'on a retrouvé le
corps du petit grégory 4 ans qui est
humain lié mardi après-midi l'enfant
jouer devant la maison de ses parents à
l'autre bout du village
au même moment son oncle reçoit un coup
de téléphone anonyme
une voix inconnue lui dis je me suis
vengé j'ai pris l'enfant
c'est vrai grégory a disparu les
gendarmes organisent une battue après
trois heures de recherches
on retrouve son corps dans la rivière
depuis quelques temps la famille étaient
harcelés ou menacés par des inconnus au
téléphone elle avait eu des coups de
téléphone anonymes des et des lettres
pareil anonyme et puis il y avait une
personne je sais pas qui a exactement
tout et vous défoncer sa porte la nuit
des choses comme ça quoi l'avait
toujours dvd menaces copie sans plus ces
derniers temps il y avait encore rue du
cheval a toujours eu quand même plus ou
moins il y en a toujours
la piste poursuivi par les enquêteurs
celle d'un règlement de compte familial
les policiers ont déjà procédé à
l'audition d'une dizaine de personne
ment ou proches de la famille
ils sont persuadés que le corbeau
connaissait très bien grégory
[Musique]
le petit grégory villemin a été inhumé
cet après midi à lépanges sur vologne
une cérémonie d'autant plus poignante
étendue que les enquêteurs ne cachaient
pas leur présence pour tenter de faire
progresser l'enquêté
certains membres de la famille s'en sont
pris à la presse sur place
isabelle bechler la petite église du
village accueille rarement autant de
monde aujourd'hui plus de 600 personnes
se sont pressées là pour accompagner le
corps de l'enfant assassiné pour
soutenir jean marie et christine
villemin ses parents ou pour voir tout
simplement
l'ambiance est lourde on sait pillon de
phase iib croire la surveillance des
gendarmes est discrète mais on sait déjà
qu'ils ont conseillé à quatre personnes
de la famille au moins de ne pas venir
pour éviter les incidents
il s'agit du clan rival celui de jackie
le demi frère de jean-marie villemin
on a beaucoup pleuré dans l'église
tout au long de la messe mais soudain
quand le petit cercueil est transporté
jusqu'au caveau
c'est comme si tous l'absurde et
l'horreur de cette mort frappe est enfin
les esprits de plein fouet trois femmes
sont tour à tour pris d'un malaise
christine la mère de grégory et les deux
grand mère de l'enfant
soudain il devient insoutenable de
penser que peut-être l'assassin est
aussi au cimetière et tout le monde
craque
c'est un peu ce que les gendarmes
chargés de l'enquêté attendaient le choc
psychologique des l'enterrement ray peut
être délié les langues qui aurait
répugné jusque là à parler du secret de
la grande famille
en effet aussi abominable que cela
paraisse les recherches dans le milieu
professionnel sont restées vaines
c'est donc vers la famille que tous les
soupçons sont désormais tournés les
quatre personnes qui étaient gardés à
vue hier soir dans le cadre de l'
enquête sur l'assassinât du petit
grégory ces quatre personnes ont été
libérées la nuit dernière et apparemment
l'enquète doit maintenant repartir à
zéro 6 à belvès hier soir la garde à vue
longue de six heures de la famille au
lard quatre parents éloignés des
villemin n'a rien donné
découragé les gendarmes renonçait vers 2
heures du matin complètement terminée
wren communiqués demain
recommencer à zéro cela signifie
repartir en quête de témoignages sur le
portrait robot de l'assassin présumé un
homme d'un mètre quatre-vingt cheveux
bruns et boucler la quarantaine
mais ce visage ne dit rien non plus à
chantal au lard un des témoins de la
veille
je connais pas aux jacuzzi ou
journalistiques alors je connais pas ce
robot vous n'avez pas une idée là des
idées les gendarmes on cherche aussi
d'arrache-pied sur le terrain cet après
midi ils ont repris à la minute près
l'emploi du temps de christine la mère
de grégory pour définir avec encore plus
de précision l'heure exacte à laquelle
elle est rentrée avec l'enfant
chronomètre en main
les gendarmes ont refait le parcours du
village à la maison davy mme ils ont
ensuite passé le reste de l'après midi
enfermé avec jean marie et christine
dans la maison à lépanges tout le monde
attend impatiemment du nouveau mais les
gendarmes restent muets nouveau
rebondissement dans une enquête menée
précisément par les gendarmes
l' enquête sur le meurtre du petit
grégory près d'epinal avec l'inculpation
aujourd'hui d'un cousin du père de la
victime bernard laroche un reportage de
fr3 dans six de bernard laroche
depuis 48 heures les gendarmes avaient
acquis la certitude que l'on aboutit
rapidement et qui ne leur manquait
désormais qu'une petite pièce du puzzle
pour comprendre et dénouer une affaire
qui secoue depuis trois semaines les
poches sur vologne et des petites
vallées vosgiennes environnantes
cette pièce les enquêteurs allaient l'a
trouvé en interrogeant ce matin muriel
une jeune fille de 15 ans elle est la
belle-soeur de bernard laroche le témoin
numéro 1 mise en garde à vue avec sa
femme mercredi dernier avant d'être
relâché le lendemain
muriel avait donné un alibi le jour du
crime pour la roche un alibi qui
devaient se révéler faux ce matin
pendant deux ans et demi jean michel
lambert le juge d'instruction a
reconstitué avec muriel le trajet
supposé de l'assassin de grégory et à
l'issue de la reconstitution le juge
déclaré je suis optimiste
on brûle à la gendarmerie de bruz hier
il est alors 12 heures et tout va
s'accélérer
le juge d'instruction et les gendarmes
prennent la direction de grand-champ
vologne et vont arrêter bernard laroche
sur son lieu de travail aux
établissements en selle la roche on
ressentira les menottes aux poignets
en fait on allait la peau à plus tard et
de bonne source
muriel aurait reconnu s'être trouvé dans
la voiture de la roche avec son fils
sébastien
tous les trois serait allé chercher
grégory pour se rendre derrière la
caserne des pompiers de docelles bernard
laroche se répartit quelques instants
avec grégory il est revenu seul pendant
plus de trois heures il sera interrogé à
la gendarmerie d'epinal assiégé par les
journalistes à 15 heures bernard laroche
quittera la gendarmerie pour le bureau
du juge
l'entretien durera 30 minutes il en
ressentira inculpé d'assassinât qu'est
ce qui vous a permis un témoignage
capital est en partie un rapport
d'expertisé
les résultats partiels ce témoignage
celui de muriel exacte et ce qu'elle
vous a dit exactement à ça je n'ai pas
besoin de vous dire un secret
d'instruction muriel à accompagner dans
la roche sur les lieux du crime
elle était dans la voiture et sébastien
son fils aussi oui c'est lui qui a servi
d'appât
pas vraiment pas vraiment pas vraiment
dur ça est-ce que j'étais dans la
voiture
est-ce que vous allez procéder à
d'autres inculpations dans l'état actuel
du dossier je l ignore totalement
reste que bernard laroche a nié tout au
long des interrogatoires brillante
journaliste un énigmatique pour nous
mais vraiment dans le coup et si les
enquêteurs sont ce sens persuadé de
tenir l'assassin de grégory reste
maintenant à comprendre les mobiles du
crime
la seconde affaire celle enquête sur
l'assassinât du petit grégory son
assassin présumé bernard laroche était
confronté cet après midi à sa belle
soeur elle s'appelle muriel elle est
âgée de 15 ans et avait été le principal
témoin à charge contre la roche dans un
tout premier temps du moins
elle s'était ensuite rétractée ce qui
n'a semble-t-il pas convaincu le juge
d'instruction le magistrat a donc
organisé aujourd'hui une rencontre entre
les deux protagonistes sur place
isabelle bechler 14h25 le fourgon de la
gendarmerie amène christian laroche au
palais de justice lors de la
confrontation est arrivée dans le bureau
du juge le suspect numéro 1 va retrouver
ses avocats maître prend avait l'air et
muriel sa belle soeur de 15 ans dans les
dépositions avait permis son inculpation
avant qu'elle ne se rétracte tout le
monde attend les curieux bien sûr la
presse mais aussi la famille de bernard
laroche
marie-ange sa femme accompagnée de la
tante louise est chez qui bernard
laroche affirme et être à l'heure du
crime
16h la confrontation se poursuit les
avocats de la roche viennent d'exiger la
présence de six nouveaux témoins pour
confirmer son alibi
parmi eux monsieur jonque à un ami avec
lequel il aurait coupé du bois jusqu'à
16 heures
sa tante louise anne jacob et chantal sa
cousine mai à 18h30 les silhouettes
furtives derrière la fenêtre du juge
reste de l'ordre de l'énigme
deux mois jour pour jour après la mort
du petit grégory ses parents ont accepté
de répondre aux questions notre envoyé
spécial isabelle bechler des parents qui
vivent ce drame avec d'autant plus
d'intensité que la presse s'en est
largement en parler vous le savez
bernard laroche le témoin numéro un dans
cette affaire est toujours en prison
une incarcération sur la foi des
témoignages de la petite muriel mais
pour les parents de grégory
l'incarcération de la roche ne suffit
pas je ne suis pas occupé à rolls on ne
s'y fait pas nous le savoir pour quoi
pour qui la fait ça il ya beaucoup de
choses qui n'ont rien
un hôtel qui dit que c'était fait
quelqu'un peut pas dire de nom mais
qu'on verra une fois son jeune complice
et une complice une jeune femme qui sait
qui c'est parce que c'est une femme qui
les arrangeait tout le monde et point
final tout ça c'était toujours une fin
qui téléphonaient non mais à ce moment
il ya une femme car liberté qui sait qui
c'est et cette femme n'avait pas de
guide et de qui ça peut être un peu
partout rien dire là-dessus on a dit ce
qu'il fallait au juge d'instruction
matin s'agit de moi ma femme aille au
bout du fil les pompes funèbres tout le
garage et médecins qui l'ont toujours
une fois qu'il est allongé et lui a peu
après appelé après tout fier de lui
disant oui tu as une surprise a eu
docteur août a eu si tu as vu ça donc
c'était bien le méchant
et si c'était pas vrai renard la roche
pour vous êtes sûr
une façon elle propre à vivre
éternellement comme c'est un jardin
secret si monstrueux c'est pas normal
déjà de la part d'une vie de 15 ans
c'est pourquoi que ça restera là
vous pensez que c'est la pression de
énorme de sa famille qui l'a fait se
rétracter jeu que les joueurs d'accord
une pression de la gendarmerie ni du
juge d'instruction se prend moins dakhla
même répétée trois fois de suite
elle a rien inventé il est en normes non
rien soufflé ça ferait bien qu
intervient le jour où l'on ne prend pas
un juif éternellement comme ça c'est pas
possible il faut quand même admettre tel
témoignage d'elisabeth qui dit quand
même que la muriel lui avais dit que je
l'avais eu bernard j'étais à saluer la
vologne
et ça quand même elle n'a pas réinventé
sans parler du reste
jean-marie vous avez repris le travail
christine non vous êtes en train de
vendre cette maison vous avez vécu
comment est ce que vous imaginez
l'avenir tribales on dit bien que les
jeunes qu'il faut repartir à zéro
c'est difficile
on essaiera toute façon en attendant on
va recommencer à zéro
mais là messieurs bonsoir décidément on
n'a pas fini d'être surpris par les
rebondissements de la sphère grégory ce
petit garçon assassiné mystérieusement à
l'automne dernier dans les vosges
on croyait l'anc est reparti sur de
nouvelles pistes et voilà qu'arrive un
deuxième meurtre
jean marie villemin le père du petit
grégory vient de tuer d'un coup de fusil
son cousin bernard laroche qui était
toujours inculpé pour le meurtre mais
qui semblait sur le point d'être
innocenté le meurtrier s'est aussitôt
rendu aux gendarmes
emilie raffoul occuper la hanche mais
aussi chez par ne rien savoir pourquoi
et pour qui la fait ça et si c'était pas
de bernard laroche
je peux le lire n'importe qui
ces innocents j'espère que le vrai
compromis sera trouvé un jour
d'accusation en dénégation de suspicion
en inculpation tout était déjà largement
compliqué dans cette affaire grégory le
meurtre aujourd'hui de bernard laroche
par jean marie villemin va-t-il
paradoxalement éclaircir les choses mais
aujourd'hui la tension a encore franchi
un pas si les proches de bernard laroche
le chose qui se produit c'est que la
justice est tellement bien fait que jean
marie villemin veut faire passer pour
fou qui va faire trois ans ou 80 de
prison ou dans maison de dalian et où
chaque rue comme ça que ce sera comme
avant le sursaut faut pas qu'ils
surprennent dans le kwassa sentir glace
3 qui sortira quand jean marie villemin
est arrivé pour ton argent genre je suis
ouvert la porte et les ai pas peur je
sais prendre n'étaient pas là quoi qu'il
arrive et si mario invités avec k la
seule chose que l'on sait c'est que
maintenant en vagabond et puis que la
police n'a pas fait son boulot
ah ça fait trois semaines qu'il était
prévenu qu' il avait menacé la menace et
bernard devaud ma belle soeur avait
téléphoné au gendarme jambert nous
aurions nous sortirait en quête se
nourrir de plus voilà ressasser la
gendarmerie française le juge lambert
actuellement en vacances doit se poser
bien des questions ce soir il se
retrouve face à un nouveau crime est
toujours sans réponse à celui de grégory
une chose est sûre tout a changé
brutalement très brutalement quelques
mois dans cette affaire avec bien sûr
d'abord l'assassinât de bernard laroche
par jean marie villemin
mais il apparaît également que christine
villemin a elle aussi beaucoup changé
hervé brusini c'est vrai qu'elle a
changé et christine villemin
aujourd'hui elle semble inébranlable
presque dur chaque jour à la une de
l'actualité
sa silhouette noire traqué par la presse
sans répit aucun à 25 ans christine
villemin est si différente de ce qu'elle
était il y a à peine huit mois
mais qui craignait sa douleur à
l'enterrement du petit grégory dans la
foule
les gendarmes sont là pouvoir aucun
doute l'assassin de l'enfant assistent à
la cérémonie tout le monde est suspect
alors comment savoir
première piste pour les enquêteurs les
lettre d'un corbeau
l'une d'elles revendique le meurtre
toute la famille qui pratiquent souvent
le coup de griffe anonyme passe à la
dictée cette première expertise désigne
bernard laroche
mais elle est annulée vice de forme
alors on recommence cette fois christine
villemin est mis en cause christine qui
est en clinique ici même enceinte elle a
perdu l'un des jumeaux qu'elle attendait
pourtant le juge lambert vient à son
chevet lui faire subir une nouvelle
dictée est à nouveau
christine et désigner les experts ne
sont toujours pas sûrs de leur fait
encore des dictées pour christine et
trois autres personnes disent qu'on a
fait réécrire
on a les mêmes caisses de questions lors
comment expertise contre expertise
on n'en finit pas de confronter
l'écriture de christine à ces lettres
est toujours la même réponse des
spécialistes à 80% nous sommes sûrs
qu'elle les a écrites
ces quatre femmes pensent la même chose
ce sont les collègues de travail de
christine elle affirme l'avoir vue
devant la poste au jour et à l'heure
même de la disparition de grégory le 16
octobre 84
christine nie tout cela elle se trompe
butelle c'est la veille que j'étais là
bas le 15 pas le 16 et puis la mise en
cause se fait plus lourde
la police judiciaire à présent chargé de
l'enquète parle d'une cordelette
retrouvées au domicile des villemin une
cordelette qui serait en tout point
semblable à celle utilisée pour ligoter
l'enfant le jour du crime
le juge comme la police ne font rien
pour stopper ces rumeurs sourde
ils font de christine l'assassin de son
propre fils
sur ce choc je combats en nutriments des
moeurs et puis comme cela même les
rumeurs sont toujours très moi et puis
que ça j'ai rien à me reprocher mais
aujourd'hui jean-marie n'est plus à ses
côtés jean marie l'homme qui décide
celui qui ira jusqu'à tuer bernard
laroche jean marie est en prison
christine affirme qu'elle le soutient
totalement et qu'il lui fais totalement
confiance pour elle leur couple est sans
faille
pourtant à la prison christine seront
tous les deux jours
jean marie va mal on la vit suicider et
christine aussi parle de mort si je suis
incarcéré dit elle je ferai une grève de
la faim
le juge aura mon deuxième enfant sur la
conscience elle est farouchement
déterminés christine villemin
la chambre d'accusation de la cour
d'appel de dijon a ordonné ce matin
l'ouverture d'un supplément
d'information avant de statuer
définitivement sur le sort de christine
villemin
celle ci fut inculpé de l'assassinât de
son fils grégory c'était au mois de
juillet 1985
grégory villemin fut découvert mort je
vous le rappelle dans la rivière la
vologne le 16 octobre 1984
ce supplément d'information n'est pas
mince 450 pages sur les 3500 du dossier
d'instruction rédigé par le juge lambert
sont à refaire
c'est un peu un camouflet pour le juge à
dijon reportage isabelle bechler noël
alexandre c'est une nouvelle lecture que
maurice simon le président de la chambre
d'accusation de la cour d'appel de dijon
propose aujourd'hui de la sphère wilm
non seulement christine villemin n'est
plus la seule suspecte à ses yeux non
seulement le président simon envisage de
rouvrir la piste laroche souvenez-vous
le premier suspect tué depuis par jean
marie villemin
mais encore selon lui le petit garçon
n'aurait pas été tuée à l'heure à
laquelle l'instruction du juge lambert
s'arrêtait le président simon suggère
que l'enfant aurait pu mourir vers 20
heures et non plus vers 17h10 les 19
minutes prêté par le juge lambert à
christine villemin pour commettre le
crime dans le village voisin et rentrer
à la maison ne signifierait donc plus
rien c'est d'ailleurs un chronométrage
que la défense avait toujours contesté
pour nous cet arrêt doucement posément
s'achemine vers la solution que nous
espérons et que nous avons toujours
espéré et qui nous paraît être celle de
la justice à savoir le non lieu pour
madame christine villemin cependant les
magistrats de dijon relève toujours dit
charge contre christine parmi lesquels
cette expertise en écriture qui la
désignent comme le corbeau est également
les témoignages de ses collègues qui
affirme l'avoir vu le jour du crime
posté une lettre à l'heure précise où le
corbeau aurait envoyé celle qui
revendiquait le meurtre de l'enfant
et l'on reparle de la sphère du petit
grégory à l'occasion des obsèques
aujourd'hui de la mère de marie ange
laroche les pousses de bernard laroche
un moment soupçonné du crime est
assassiné par son beau frère jean marie
villemin la polémique vient du fait que
l'un des avocats de la famille laroche
estime que c'est la récente libération
provisoire de gens
marie villemin en attendant son jugement
qui a choqué la mère de marie ange
laroche au point de décéder d'une crise
cardiaque à l'âge de 57 ans et le moins
que l'on puisse dire c'est que
l'atmosphère était particulièrement
tendue pendant la cérémonie des obsèques
cet après midi isabel peichert lave
ligne devant bruyère vosges dans cette
vallée de la vologne où les victimes de
la serre grégory ne se comptent plus le
deuil a encore frappé du côté des
laroche
jeanine bol est décédé voilà trois jours
à l'âge de 57 ans elle était mère de dix
enfants dont marie-ange la veuve de
bernard laroche et muriel qui avait mis
en cause son beau-frère pour toute cette
famille la vie avait basculé avec la
faire voilà trois ans vraiment entre eux
aussi vraiment ayad la justice je veux
qu'il faut chercher la chose et qu'on
sache la vérité une vérité est acquis
c'est jean marie villemin qui a tué
bernard laroche le libérer c'était comme
tuer bernard une seconde fois pour sa
famille
après un moment de consternation au
moment d'un d'ignacio au moment de
colère et après la tristesse provoqué
par la mort de madame ball mère de marie
ange laroche et grand mère de sébastien
laroche qui n'a pas supporté le choc et
qui en est morte
c'est une volonté de justice que jean
marie villemin passe aux assises mais
aussi de volonté que ce dossier soit
confié dossier d'instruction de mort de
grégory villemin le dossier
d'instruction concernant la plainte
contre les gendarmes se confiait à un
magistrat qui ne soit pas le juge simon
qui a montré trop de partialité aux yeux
de la famille laroche la libération de
jean marie villemin traduit la volonté
d'étouffer la faire et non pas de
rechercher la vérité au cours jean marie
villemin assassins de bernard laroche
des loges je ne suis pas convaincu que
l'on veut vraiment trouver l'assassin de
grégory villemin
vous ne verrez de cet enterrement qu'un
cimetière vide dans sa douleur et son
indignation la famille n'a pas pu
maîtriser sa colère des menaces et des
voies de fait ont découragé les
journalistes présents dans la région
nouveau rebondissement dans l'affairé
grégory médiatique est surprenant le
très discret juge simon se met à parler
au point qu'il a confirmé lui même tout
à leur plainte a été déposée contre lui
les détails véronique d'aurel pour la
deuxième fois en deux mois le juge simon
rompt le silence je sais avait il
déclaré à une chaîne de télévision
aujourd'hui il va beaucoup plus loin
trois révélations pour un entretien au
nouveau détective 1
le juge simon semble convaincu de
l'heure du crime le petit grégory
auraient été noyés après 17h30 à cette
heure-là christine villemin participent
déjà aux recherches une heure qui
innocenteraient la mère de grégory
deuxième révélation le petit grégory
aurait été assassiné par plusieurs
personnes trois hypothèses sont retenues
les trois rivaux que bernard laroche
peut être at il relevé gregori de là à
être son assassinat il y à un pack pour
le moment je ne peux pas franchir ajoute
le juge réaction vive et immédiate de
l'avocat de marie-ange laroche
ils demandent que le juge simon soit
dessaisi pour violation du secret de
l'instruction
un juge qui ne respectent pas les règles
de l'instruction reste il à magistrat
instructeur crédible je vous pose la
question la réponse est évidemment non
alors comment cela va se passer c'est ce
que nous voulons dire avec voir avec le
garde des sceaux et à lui d'agir pour
que la justice à dijon fonctionne comme
doit fonctionner la justice française
troisième révélation le juge simon
affirme avoir reçu des menaces de mort
contre lui et ses petits enfants
ce qui me trouble dit il c'est que seuls
les grands parents de grégory
connaissent l'existence de ma famille
l'avocat de monique albert villemin
attend un démenti écoutez ça serait
extrêmement grave imaginer qu'un
magistrat instructeur pense que les
parties civiles
par lettre anonyme il sera à ce moment
là impossible de travailler ensemble
ce soir le juge simon s'était interrogé
à sa sortie du palais de justice de
dijon il a simplement répondu il y à une
plainte contre moi je répondrai devant
le juge kim interrogera autre silence
compréhensible celui de jean marie et
christine villemin
il se refuse ce soir à tout commentaire
le reste de l'actualité avec tout
d'abord la sphère grégory épilogue
judiciaire puisque la chambre
d'accusation de la cour d'appel de dijon
doit se prononcer sur la culpabilité de
christine villemin
huit ans après les faits le procureur
général lui s'est prononcé pour un non
lieu
c'est à dire l'innocence le reportage de
josé gonzalez
une fois encore jean marie et christine
villemin doivent se frayer un chemin
entre la quarantaine de journalistes
présents une nouvelle fois christine
villemin doit se présenter devant des
magistrats après huit ans d'instruction
mais peut-être est-ce pour elle la
dernière fois l'avocat général demande
le non lieu pour la mère du petit
grégory la défense de jean marie et
christine villemin est d'accord bien sûr
mais france 3 lorraine le révélé jeudi
dernier la partie civile
albert et monique villemin parents de
jean marie grands parents de grégory
souhaite un supplément d'information
objectif utiliser un ordinateur
récemment mise au point très performant
pour comparer la voix enregistrée du
corbeau qui menaçait la famille avec
celle de toutes les personnes impliquées
dans le dossier y compris
christine villemin or aujourd'hui et on
ne les compte plus coup de théâtre ce
qui concerne le non lieu de christine
villemin
il y avait si j'ose dire l'union sacrée
l'union sacrée entre la partie civile le
ministère public et la défense
l'union sacrée en clair les grands
parents renoncent à utiliser ce nouvel
ordinateur pour comparer entre autres la
voix de christine villemin est celle du
corbeau pourquoi il souhaite que jean
marie soient jugés plus vite possible et
il pense que dans l'immédiat c'est
prématuré
et c'est à dire que jean marie à
téléphoner à ses parents c'est ce que
nous pensons et d'ailleurs c'est un
secret pour personne et sans réponse est
lié et nous ne ferons rien qui aille
contre les intérêts de jean marie
les magistrats dijonnais vont se donner
le temps de la réflexion la sphère sera
mise en délibéré
christine villemin inculpé pour le
meurtre de son fils depuis le 5 juillet
85 devra attendre quelques semaines
encore
nouveauté
procès villepin sur la mort du petit
grégory mais les médecins légistes
entendu aujourd'hui ont fait aveu
d'ignorance ils ont été incapables de
dire quand et comment le petit garçon a
été assassiné isabelle staes eric de
lannion au commencement d'une enquête
il y avait deux médecins légistes dont
le docteur pages elle c'est elle qui a
pratiqué l'autopsié de gregor
il portait un bonnet un anorak il avait
une cordelette autour du cou des mains
et des chevilles les liens n'était pas
du tout serré le juge lambert lui aussi
était là il ne voulait pas du tout qu'on
fasse les prélèvements accuse le docteur
pagelles ça nous a surpris
on a insisté on a juste obtenu
l'autorisation de prélever du sang et
les poumons en omettant de faire tous
les prélèvements
on a réduit les possibilités de faire la
lumière en chaîne le professeur lebreton
l'enfant noyées dans l'eau de la vologne
je dis non il n'y avait pas de corps
étrangers dans les poumons
le docteur marc un juge le propos de son
confrère excessif mais il s'étonne
pourtant que l'enfant ne se soient pas
débattues pour se dégager de ses liens
il ne portait pas de marque
grégory était il inconscient c'est
probable mais c'est pas sûr
les questions fusent mais chaque réponse
des médecins d'ong comme un aveu
d'impuissance
neuf ans après les faits tout le
problème est de savoir si l'enfant est
mort noyé avant d'être jeté dans la
vologne a résumé l'un des médecins
terrible constat dans une bataille
d'experts où la seule certitude
aujourd'hui est une autopsie bâclé qui a
sans doute fossé tout l'anc est jean
marie villemin a supplié aujourd'hui
muriel bolle de dire la vérité sur la
mort de son fils grégory muriel bolle a
dit sa vérité bernard laroche n'a pas
tué grégory pas payant chaque matin et
ce depuis six semaines jean marie
villemin a tant que muriel dise la
vérité sur la mort de son enfant
aussi aujourd'hui c'est lui qui passe en
syrie cherchant à son tour à
déstabiliser le témoin tu as deux
enfants dont l'un à 4 ans l'âge qu'avait
grégory aujourd'hui grégory devoir 13
ans il faut que le retard je puisse
regarder tes enfants en face si tu peux
vivre avec un secret aussi monstrueux je
te plains muriel ne se démonte pas ordre
je n'ai pas de secret c'est quand même
en toi qui as
saint bernard et bernard il est innocent
pour la quatrième fois depuis le début
du procès venture ober fait aulas à la
cour d'assises
il est évident que muriel n'a pas été
maltraités physiquement et moralement
elle a subi une pression psychologique
délicat le juge lambert ajoute elle
avait 15 ans et elle n'est pas non plus
une année les duels ces pressions muriel
bolle la subite de nouveau depuis quatre
jours sans que personne ne réussisse à
trouver la faille
pourtant les villemin muriel bolle s'est
enferré dans un mensonge et la partie
civile n'a qu'un seul appui à l'issue de
cette sixième semaine de procès jean
michel lambert et une fois de lui le
petit con semble être un homme bien seul
la justice a donné son feu vert à la
réouverture de l'enquêté sur l'affairé
grégory des analyses génétiques vont
donc être effectués sur le timbre d'une
lettre envoyée par le corbeau
de nouveaux éléments qui pourraient
conduire sur la piste de celui qui a
assassiné le petit garçon clément
weill-raynal benoît verront la décision
de la cour d'appel de dijon est une
première dans l'histoire judiciaire la
chambre d'accusation a en effet estimé
que le progrès scientifique constitue en
soi un élément nouveau permettant la
réouverture d'une enquête qu'il était
définitivement close en l'occurrence
celle de l' affaire grégory
en conséquence la chambre d'accusation
ordonne qu'une recherche d'adr soit
effectuée sous le timbre d'une lettre
envoyée par un mystérieux corbeau aux
parents du petit grégory en 1983 soit
plus de 18 mois avant l'assassinât de
l'enfant
si nous pouvons en effet identifié le
corbeau scripteur du printemps 1983
nous aurons des éléments pour identifier
le corbeau à seyssins de l'automne 1984
mais ses personnages peuvent être
différents alors ça peut être le même
personnage
il y aura les difficultés que nous
connaissons et nous voulons continuer
cette procédure avec beaucoup de calme
et de sérénité
seize ans après l'assassinât du petit
grégory la sphère pourrait-elle être
relancée et le terrible secret de
l'avant
owni enfin percer aujourd'hui les paons
je veux tu oublié tous les protagonistes
du drame quittait le village
seuls les parents de grégory espère
encore découvrir la vérité c'est
christine villemin elle-même et son mari
jean marie qui ont été à l'origine à la
fin du mois de novembre 1999 de cette
demande de faisabilité pour déterminer
si oui ou non les progrès de la science
pouvait amener attentes et d'espérer un
jour approcher la vérité parce que
l'assassinât d'un petit garçon de 4 ans
ne peut pas rester impuni
moi je crains qu'on rallume les passions
sans arriver à la vérité
et n'oublions pas qu'en ce qui concerne
les familles villemin les familles
laroche et tous les protagonistes
ils ont aujourd'hui pris de l'âge c'est
bastien qui a vu son enfant son père
assassiné devant ses yeux sébastien
larouche sébastien laroche a aujourd'hui
15 ans lucile à 19 ans les enfants
villemin ont grandi les odeurs envie
demain ce qui bon tous les protagonistes
ont grandi ce que je crains c'est de
rallumer les patients sans atteindre la
vérité mais la chambre d'accusation
estimé que cette recherche de la vérité
mérite est la réouverture du dossier
les résultats de l'expertisé pourrait
être connu dès le mois de septembre
[Musique]